i've long been fascinated with college
sports
i grew up down south where college
football is a religion
i saw up close the power of hoya
basketball when i went to georgetown
and now i've got a son set to play
college lacrosse
and that's giving me a whole new window
into that world and as with everything
i see a business story right now a
first-year lacrosse player at a division
three school like my son
and trevor lawrence clemson's
championship winning quarterback and
widely touted
nfl star well they have something in
common
neither of them are allowed to be paid a
dime while they play sports at the
college level
and that may be about to change i think
2021 will be a pivotal year for college
sports for a lot of reasons
we've been talking about a potential
tipping point in college sports
this may be the time with the pandemic
with the racial justice issues
with the activity at the federal and
state level
with the activity at the supreme court
that we say this is no longer a
sustainable model
schools are conspiring with competitors
agreeing with competitors to pay
no salaries to the workers who are
making the schools billions of dollars
on the theory that consumers want the
schools to pay their workers nothing
after years of asking the question will
paying college athletes destroy college
athletics
it looks like finally in 2021 that
question will be answered
the tipping point is here
[Music]
college sports was built on the idea of
amateurism
more than a hundred years ago after the
death of 18 students and injuries to 150
others
the ncaa was formed as a non-profit its
mission
to protect the lives of football players
by adding new rules to the sport
the biggest being the advent of the
forward pass one of the core tenets
these were not professional athletes
immaturism is defined in the ncaa's
465-page manual
as being motivated primarily by
education and by the physical
mental and social benefits to be derived
protected from exploitation by
professional and commercial enterprises
in lieu of paying the players schools
provide athletes with scholarships
but today between the college football
championships touchdown
devonte smith cannot be stopped and
march madness
how about that the ncaa is a
money-making machine
with nearly 19 billion in revenue in
2019 alone
and the students they still don't get
paid
when and how did it get so out of
control like
was there a catalytic moment or was this
just
a slow bleed as it were the explosion in
revenues
came from another supreme court
anti-trust case
called board of regents 37 years ago
jeffrey kessler is the co-lead counsel
for the basketball and football players
who are suing the ncaa for greater
economic rights
what happened in board of regents is the
supreme court ruled
that the ncaa could not restrict
the broadcast of college football
and had to allow the conferences and the
schools
to compete with each other it led to an
explosion
in television revenues both in college
football and then derivatively in
college basketball
rather than two networks broadcasting a
total of 14 college football games each
week
more than 15 networks careless nearly
every college football game on tv
more games led to more ad revenue and
events like
lsu sits on the throne of college
football
the college football championship brings
in close to half a billion dollars in
revenue every year
that revenue ends up influencing how
college sports is organized
there was a great kind of realignment if
you will of a number of
uh of the of the major conferences
this is amy privet perco executive
director of the night commission
an independent group that spearheads
reform in college athletics and that was
really done
to increase the footprint of those
conferences for the football tv market
and what may work
for the football tv market may not
be the best solution for all the other
sport programs
while there are more than 350 division 1
basketball schools they're only 130 in
football
also known as the football bowl
subdivision or fbs
that's led to a great imbalance in
school's athletic budgets
fbs college football is the most
powerful sport
in college sports from the standpoint of
the finances
and shaping the entire landscape
because the money in football you have
athletic programs in division one
whose budgets are five million dollars a
year and they're competing
in the same division in basketball with
universities
that have athletic department budgets of
more than 200 million dollars a year
college football already rakes in money
hand over fist but the new playoff
system
is about to make it more profitable than
ever according to cnn the 64 schools
that compete for a spot in that final
game
brought in a combined 2.8 billion
dollars last season
and with billions of dollars now coming
into ncaa programs
that money needs to be spent the phrase
they use in economics is rent seeking
behavior
this is my colleague joe no sarah a
bloomberg opinion writer and author
who's been delving into the inequalities
of college sports for more than a decade
that means money has to go somewhere and
with division 1 basketball and football
being the lion's share of where the
revenue comes from
the money goes straight back into those
programs where is it going to go
goes to the administrators it goes to
the conference commissioners it goes to
the coaches it goes to the assistant
coaches it goes to the weight coaches
it goes to these fancy buildings it goes
to a new
football stadium nick saban makes north
of
five and a half million dollars a year
very simply is he worth it to the
university of alabama
nick saban's the best financial
investment this university has ever made
about 45 of the 50 states where either
the basketball coach or the football
coach is the highest paid state employee
however there is one place that money
does not go
they all say well we can't afford to pay
the players
of course you can afford to pay the
players you've just chosen
not to for years the ncaa has made two
main
arguments the first well they are paid
we're here to educate them help them
grow as people we're not here to help
them
in terms of their financial gain the
second being that paying players would
take away from college sports quote
spirit of amateurism and some people do
agree with those sentiments
even some of the players i think on the
financial side
what the influx of you know
monetary incentives has done is it just
made that process a little bit harder
right this is kendall spencer former
track star at the university of new
mexico
olympic hopeful and the first student to
ever sit on the ncaa division one board
when i reflect on just ideally what i
would want a student-athlete to be
thinking about
when they were choosing their
institution was you know where can i go
to not only get this great athletic
experience
and you know maybe i'm trying to make an
olympic team or maybe i'm trying to make
the professional leagues but
beyond that where can i go where i get
what i need academically so that no
matter
what happens i'm going to be successful
kendall and others argue that this is
actually what the current model
accomplishes for the vast
vast majority of athletes they say that
reforms shouldn't
unduly punish those true student
athletes in the process of reforming a
system
that's been undermined by two big money
sports
so for some a strong education really is
the best compensation they can get for
playing college sports
but the money is hard to ignore and the
pandemic
made it even harder
tonight the ncaa president says there
will be no fall championships except for
the college football playoff
the money was so important for the
universities
they were going to play football come
hell or high water it didn't really
matter
if the athletes got covered they were
going to play
they'd always said you know they're
students first and you know
athletes second and we want to think
they're there for an education
so here you had a situation where most
of the rest of the university
in many cases was not even on campus we
reached out to the ncaa about the health
risks posed to players
but they didn't respond and critics say
that the cancelling of one sport but the
continuation of another solely because
of financial reasons
makes the ncaa's amateurism argument
moot
the mythology that
d1 basketball and fbs
football was just like another
extracurricular activity as if it were
you know rowing you know or this
or the newspaper or the drama club
when in fact these have become
gigantic businesses that are completely
independent of the educational mission
of these schools
and in college sports there was not only
the argument that if we pay the players
it will destroy the sport this is gabe
feldman
he's a professor of sports law at tulane
university
and overall expert on all things ncaa
there was this added layer that if we
pay the players
that will mean that much of the benefit
will flow to a relatively small number
of players
and the other sports will be hurt so
we'll end up with
college football and maybe some men's
and women's basketball but
rowing and swimming and diving and
golfing lacrosse that'll all
collapse because schools are struggling
to make money
so if the pandemic laid bare the
importance of college football revenue
and the ncaa stood firm on not paying
players
could there be a middle ground i think
there were plenty of people who bought
that argument
accepted that we will do damage to
college sports as a whole
if we provide compensation for football
and basketball players and so
name image and likeness rights were seen
as i think a compromise
as a workable solution that would
provide benefits for college athletes
compensation for name image and likeness
or nil
doesn't involve college's paying players
but does allow athletes to benefit from
their accomplishments
as the schools conferences tv networks
and others
already are help me understand how nil
fits into sort of the larger argument
nil for the benefit of those watching
are the rights
to exploit an athlete's name image and
likeness
and the payment for those rights doesn't
really come from the schools
and that's one of the reasons these
schools should not be upset about nil
it doesn't come out of their pocket it's
like
it's like you're making the players
happy and you don't have to pay anything
no institutional involvement no direct
or even indirect money from the colleges
originally the nil debate focused around
avatars and ea sports video games
in ea ncaa basketball 09 an unnamed ucla
player looked exactly like
and played the same position as ed
o'bannon a former ucla basketball player
this led to a bannon v ncaa an
anti-trust class
action lawsuit filed against the ncaa
that challenged their use of its
athletes likeness for commercial
purposes i don't think we can overlook
the impact that ed o'bannon has had
on this when he filed his lawsuit to try
to get compensation for
former and current college athletes he
lost the case
at least as pertaining to nil but i
think he showed a path forward
and i think he helped start to convince
people
that it's possible to both save and
protect college sports and maybe even
strengthen college sports
while also providing more rights for
college athletes
while the supreme court ultimately
declined to hear the o'bannon case
the focus for nil has now shifted away
from video games
and towards social media it's hard to
ignore
that this is no longer just about the
traditional endorsement team this is no
longer just about the star
athlete getting the deal with the
apparel company and the opportunities
that has provided for young people in
this innovation economy
when an athlete comes on campus and they
have more than a million followers
why can't they then monetize their
popularity
if you're a musician you can record
something and you can get hey everyone
else at the school is allowed to take
advantage if you have those
opportunities
except the athletes who want to play
ncaa sports
katie ledecky probably the most famous
swimmer in the country
right now actually had to resign
from competing any longer on the
stanford
swimming team because the loss of her
potential revenues
got to a point where in consultation
with her family she just said she
couldn't give it up
anymore there should be some
requirements for transparency
and institutions should not be involved
in setting up these deals
and there should be no use of the
institutional mark because again this is
about allowing the individuals as
athletes to be able to
um benefit from their name image and
likeness not that of the university
one thing nil and directly paying the
players have in common
is the ncaa has fought against both for
decades
so why do you think they resisted so
much because that's the system they
resisted because that's the way it's
always been
they do worry about the disparity
between
the quarterback getting a car ad and hit
the center
getting nothing the reality is and
that's what our
anti-trust laws established is
competition
leads generally to more fan interest
more revenues and a fairer allocation
of the revenues to the people who
actually generate them
and over the past few years the fight
for nil has gotten
messy with no action by the ncaa and
no national standard individual states
chose to step in
in september 2019 california initiated
the fair pay to play that allowed
athletes to be paid
for their name image and likeness other
states like florida followed suit and on
top of all that
the supreme court has heard oral
arguments in the pivotal
ncaa versus alston case with judges
making arguments in both directions
and some staying above the fray it's a
tough case for me
this is not an ordinary product so i
worry a lot about judges getting into
the business
of deciding how amateur sports should be
run
one of the things that it's hard for i
think an outsider to totally comprehend
is
you've got california you've got florida
you've got the supreme court you've got
the ncaa
when you cut through it where does this
really kind of
come down to like who ultimately is
going to be sort of
the decider here there is a legitimate
reason why you want
one set of nil rules right because
otherwise
you really get into this thing where 50
states have 50 different rules
and it's a it's a mess we are dealing
with a situation
i've compared to the ncaa is now
juggling fiery knives
and the knives that are up in the air
are
an amateurism antitrust decision there's
activity at the state level the federal
level the supreme court level
there are lawsuits still being filed
there's the nil legislation
there's the public pressure and there's
frankly not even agreement within the
ncaa about what
the right path forward is you'd have
recruiting advantages you know
based on what your nil is in california
versus what your niel is in maryland
the most logical place for this to be
sorted out is congress
i want to save college sports but i
don't necessarily think
that kids shouldn't get any share of the
money that is increasingly
making people in this industry
millionaires
that's senator chris murphy from
connecticut a die-hard yukon fan and one
of the most outspoken members of
congress when it comes to nil
and that's why i've introduced
legislation that would create a
federal right to make money off of your
name image and likeness and that's why
i'm supportive of broader efforts that
would
you know create some federal
expectations around broader revenue
sharing
with student athletes senator murphy
isn't the only member of congress taking
on nil
his co-sponsor in the house is
representative lori trahan of
massachusetts who herself is a former d1
volleyball player
at georgetown go hoyas another bill in
congress the college
athlete's bill of rights was introduced
by cory booker and richard blumenthal
both democrats from new jersey and
connecticut respectively
it seeks quote fair and equitable
compensation
for college athletes we reached out to
the ncaa for comment and they directed
us to a written statement reading
the board of directors remains fully
committed to providing student athletes
with appropriate opportunities
within the collegiate model by
modernizing division one rules related
to name image and likeness and transfer
eligibility at the first
practicable opportunity if we're going
to
make a good case for congress they need
to
understand that all the universities
within the ncaa
want to see the same outcome because
timing is critical here
because we're frankly at a point where
the first state law will go into effect
in july
and we're leading toward chaos that's
not going to be good for athletes or the
universities
and so what do you worry about kind of
getting in the way what are the
obstacles here to getting this done
this industry is incredibly powerful i i
think that you know the power five
schools um are not going to be
interested in changing the status quo
and i think that's largely because the
power now exists in individual
school athletic programs and individual
conferences
not in the ncaa
and he's right the power in decision
making for allocating revenue has
shifted from the ncaa
to what's called the power five or the
five most prestigious athletic
conferences
in america one of the things that
a lot of sports fans college sports fans
for example don't really understand
is that the ncaa does not control the
college football
playoff and the 500 million dollars a
year generated by the college football
playoff
is handled independently of the ncaa the
fbs institutions received that funding
this fits into sort of some even bigger
questions
it feels like around how colleges
operate how they spend their money
it's long overdue to have a conversation
about recalibrating revenue
and costs in college sports also
recalibrating the governance structure
in division one sports and the night
commission has been looking into these
issues
for a very long time and continues to do
so
there's significant opportunities here
because
the growth in the media revenues is not
going to go away
we've seen over time it continues to
increase in college sports
some of the challenges really are a
result of its success in media revenues
but we haven't met the moment of the
challenges
by changing the system by changing the
incentives
to really ensure that those revenues are
going to the right places
and going to support a healthy system
across
all sports not just football and
basketball
while much is made of how much money
pours into and swirls around
big time college football and basketball
senator murphy and other proponents of
nil reform
say the biggest beneficiaries may not be
the star athletes like trevor lawrence
and zion williamson
who would simply be getting a down
payment on a future fortune
the real winners may be athletes at top
tier college programs
like the fabled yukon women's basketball
team some of whom may
ultimately eke out a living playing
professional basketball but whose best
chance of being compensated for their
talents
may come in college
managing a vaccine rollout and an
ensuing economic recovery will likely
push senator murphy's bill
and other legislation until later in the
year
in the meantime we'll get a look at how
athletes may or may not benefit
from state legislation the ncaa may opt
to take this
issue up again and the supreme court
will likely issue
its ruling by the summer 2021
may bring some semblance of change or it
could bring
an entirely new business model to
college sports
one that actually includes the athletes
thanks so much for watching would love
to hear what you think about this
and other episodes about the business of
sports i'll be in the comments section
can't wait to hear what you think